hey youtubers is Charlie so this week
agents of shield wrapped up what they
started in the first episode last week
introduced the next big villain
character as well as a plot that I think
is gonna spill into the phase three
movies so lots of stuff to get through
grab yourself some damn fine coffee and
we'll talk about what the hell just
happened I'll wait just a sec for you
guys to get that coffee okay ready there
we go top five moments number five fit
smack is the new Fitzsimmons that's what
I'm calling Fitz and Mack it also brings
up the point about Simmons where the
hell is she
they're basically saying she bailed but
based on the teaser for the next episode
something else is going on so I'll talk
about that later in this video
Fitz though seems like he's continuing
to slide off the deep end
I noticed he seemed much more lucid when
he was hallucinating Simmons than when
he was talking to normal people the
performance just felt a little
inconsistent and at some point they're
really gonna have to explain these
hallucinations
I'm guessing Mack is gonna be the one to
call him out on it but Closen knows that
he's hallucinating right now I think
that Fitz could go a couple of ways
either his brains gonna explode from
trauma or whatever's going on with him
could help him unlock the secrets of the
universe and hack the obelisk Tech based
on the teaser for the next episode -
cracking could also try to hack Fitz his
brain or they could use whatever device
they have jacked into that person I'm
really hoping that fits his problem ties
in with unlocking the obelisk I feel
like when you suffer brain injuries in
the Marvel Universe you can see across
time and space it's like getting dumped
in vats of radioactive waste
you know you get powers I mean that's
how it works in the comic book universe
really digging Fitz and Mack together
though I know everyone wanted Mack to
turn out to be Luke Cage that is not the
case I don't think I think they're gonna
roll out Luke Cage whenever they start
doing the Netflix shows next year the
other big thing that I'm really hoping
is gonna happen because we're really
early in the season
is that crazy Fitz is gonna tie in with
the crazy Coulson plot with him drawing
all the symbols and unlocking the
obelisk like I'm hoping all those things
will just kind of dovetail together
number 4 Coulson needs some dry erase
markers did anyone else wonder that
while he was carving that board up it
seemed like he was just spackling over
it after he finished each time it seemed
like there was like a bucket of spackle
to the side so like he'd carve it up Mei
would take pictures they Chronicle it
and then he'd erase his tracks like he'd
erase his work it's too bad he's not
saving those I bet he could earn a ton
of money selling him on Etsy it's like
crazy coffee tables I'm pretty sure that
there's demand for coffee tables with
celestial language graffiti all over it
the 18 days thing I feel like is pretty
important too like it's part of some
cycle Coulson is on that's gonna tie
into something that's gonna be going on
with the obelisk here's some of my early
theories about this one it could be gem
related Tech as in the soul gems are
conscious entities capable of pushing
their will so maybe the obelisk is tied
to a gem and the gem is just inception
the way the tesseract inception Hawkeye
and dr. Selvig it could be one of the
gems just trying to bring about some
sort of predetermined outcome think
about it this way the power behind the
obelisk
whether it's gem or tear gene crystal
related it's communicating with Coulson
trying to get him to do something
Coulson just hasn't figured out what
that is yet Terrigen crystals do not
really work that way gems can do that
though and based on the way that Raina
and Skye's father were talking about the
obelisk
it makes me think it's more gem related
than Terrigen crystal related I don't
think that the obelisk is a straight-up
gem I do think it's connected to the
gems though number three absorbing man
absorbs the obelisk
I like that it's effect on and went
beyond his metahuman physiology I think
we're just meant to take away the
diabolos is more alien and more powerful
than anyone understands not including
the captain though he seems to be the
only one who has a clue what's going on
the Hydra person that creel was working
with was able to talk him down so
whatever the obelisk did to him its
effects aren't really clear right now
it's not clear if there's any lasting
effects he did get away with rayna's
carbide ring the whole purpose of that
was just at Eason is being potentially
indestructible when she said store
energy did anyone just wonder whether or
not he'd be able to take a blast from
the destroyer gun I feel like that's the
real tease for the future of absorbing
man he's just gonna become so powerful
that Coulson and Talbot won't be able to
take him down with conventional energy
weapons right now he's neutralized but
Coulson explained
he's only been turned to rock and even
that won't stick so expect
the absorbing man back in a future
episode not next week but eventually
number two Black Panthers shout out this
wasn't necessarily a Black Panther
teaser I think the characters big enough
that they'd want to intro him in one of
the movies the reference was Operation
Panther Claw though they never said what
Conda but the interesting thing about
that place is that it has extremely
advanced technology so if they're
dealing with gem related technology or
Kree tech or whatever the obelisk is
what Conda could be a place for them to
go where they can get help and my number
one moment of course Kyle MacLachlan
is the doctor his name right now is just
the doctor they haven't revealed his
first or last name right off the bat
here's what I think he is a human like
he's not an alien in disguise he's very
clearly not working with Hydra which
means now we're up to three factions for
if you include the military there's team
Coulson which you could also consider
team Avengers Hydra and Kraken and now
this new group with Raina and the doctor
he's not confirmed evil he's just
someone who seems very interested in his
own plans the big question now is is
that based on the big plan that Raina
teased
who are these people and what is this
obelisk the first thing my mind goes to
is obviously Inhumans and Kree Tech we
only saw the Kree in guardians of the
galaxy for a brief moment
not including Ronan but the Kree were
behind the Terrigen crystals in the
comics and the crystals were responsible
for the creation of the Inhumans it's
possible they're modifying the origins
of the Inhumans just to work within the
Marvel Cinematic Universe
they did the same thing with Ultron like
they changed Ultron's backstory they
could be doing the exact same thing with
the Inhumans the other important thing
to consider is that during guardians the
collector explained the gems and the
Celestials so it's possible that these
markings are the language of the
Celestials because they're the ones that
originally contained the gems that still
doesn't explain who Kyle MacLachlan is
he could be a character from the comics
we're just gonna have to wait to find
out because next week is a big Hydra
story let me know what your favorite
moment was and big question do you think
that the obelisk is tied to an Inhumans
storyline remember Marvel could just be
swapping the Terrigen crystals for like
gem related technology
the big things to look out for in
Episode three next week our Kraken who
we'll learn a bunch more about and we'll
learn what Simmons has been doing with
Hydra apparently my guess is is that
she's just been trying to infiltrate
them she seems too pure to have turned
evil but I'm looking forward to some
Hydra related comedy Simmons is
typically a character that's used for
comedies so I'm sure we'll get some
funny Simmons Hydra moments so overall I
gave the episode a solid a - just for an
amazing execution of a two-part story
this basically be in the second half
technically it was not a two-parter but
the story was such a continuation of the
events from the first episode it should
have been called part two the show also
earns a ton of extra points for wasting
no time in mapping out the big players
of the season and telling us what
they're going after like it's a very
clear path the doctor and Reina are
trying to unlock the powers of the
obelisk and get Skye I'm actually
guessing that Skye is gonna be the key
to controlling the obelisk why else
would he want her so badly it doesn't
seem like it was love that inspired him
to order Reina to get Skye then there's
Hydra and kraken who also want the
obelisk but at the same time wanna
Bogart all the rest of shield's
resources world domination
so 1945 then there's Coulson who's
trying to unlock the mysteries of the
celestial language while cleaning up the
Hydra mess and keeping the world from
falling apart so right now the thing
that's really getting me sucked into the
story that's really keeping me
interested is trying to see how all
these characters and their side plots
are connected
obviously the obelisk is like the
MacGuffin it's the thing that's gonna be
pushing the plot forward and all these
other things we'll have to connect it by
the end of the year in terms of
performances I think absorbing mance is
gonna totally be an interesting
recurring character he got a lot more
dialog in this episode so his character
is you know percolating it's developing
I think he'll get better with time
Coulson of course always tons of fun I'm
really happy to see Raina back - she was
one of the most interesting new
characters last season all in all the
show is just feeling more and more like
a movie every week which is amazing I
never expect that kind of thing from a
simple TV show but shield is definitely
throwing down the gauntlet in front of
the other comic book shows this year air
on the flash I think are definitely
after the challenge so it's gonna be a
lot of fun because I have some extra
time this week
again I'm gonna be doing another Q&A
just like I did last week so be sure to
subscribe to get that leave all your
questions I also live tweet a lot of the
episodes so if you want to play along
the links for my social or down in the
description but right now you can click
here to get that Q&A I'll add the
annotation as soon as I post it and
click here for my episode 1 video thank
you so much for watching there's a lot
of fun everybody watch the episode and
we'll meet up tomorrow high fives
you